Hey Good Morning my friends Welcome Back Today I have A very Short and Sweet Video for you I've got an Experimental Prototype of A
Project I was working With last nights that I want to reveal and Share With you for the first Time now you might Remember These
Things These Are Silicone Pokeball Molds that
We made in A previous Project and ever Since I made them I've Been Inundated with requests to cast
Chocolate Pokeballs so Last Night I did Decide To try Something on in Those lines but
Was a little bit of A twist let me Show you what i mean I?
Love the Way that this Just Peels Apart
Almost Effortlessly and That Looks Pretty Cool Right There
other Side Here
Oop There, We go there it Is that Looks Pretty cool?
Looking Good
and
There's The Relief
Look at that Guy's A beautiful Battle-Tested Chocolate Pokeball that Looks Amazing but There's One other Characteristic that I'm Really Proud
Of that I want to show you next the cool thing about These pokéballs not only are They
Made of Dark Chocolate but if you listen Closely and Give Them a shake
You Can Actually Hear a liquid Sloshing Around on the Inside
Actually does Sound Really cool
So what Could Possibly be on the Inside this Is what I'm Most excited to show you?
Now I just went out and Randomly Found this Rock with a relatively Sharp
Edge On it and I like the curve on this Because i Can stick my finger on it for Leverage
Let's Use This Little Improvised tool to go Ahead and Crack the pokeball so, we Can split it Into Two Halves, oh?
Look at that Look at that
On the inside We Actually Have Coconut Water and
Different Layers of Colors Too we've Got Brown white we've got this Liquidy stuff as, well
Hmm
The Really Cool Thing About This Liquidy Stuff
Is it's not Water it's Actually Sprite you Can see where I cracked it on the Top There it just Kind of Flaked away
But it Made A Relatively Clean Crack Around the rest of it the chocolate wasn't super Thick but that Could be Easily?
Accomplished By Just Leaving the Chocolate in A little bit Longer
So that's good to know
Now Just for fun I did go Ahead and Make two of These that means we've got a second, one We Can crack here
We go chi who
Oops There Goes There, We go beautiful the coolest thing is the Shell Is Edible as well?
And what I really love about These things They Emulate a coconut very
Well the Only Difference Is They're Completely Made of Candy?
Dark Chocolate on the Outside White Chocolate on the inside and Fill the Sprite how cool Is that
But We Made These using pokeball molds so rather than Calling them Coconut I think it might [Be] more Appropriate to Call them pokey nut
So how
do
We get the Sprite to stay Inside I'm not going to tell you in This Video Because I think you're smart Enough to Figure it
out for Yourself and if You do leave your thoughts in the Comments Below
Thanks for Joining Me for This Experiment Guys and I'll be Looking for you the next Video Talk to you then
Wouldn't it be cool if These [things] Actually Grew on Coconut Trees?
Hey Guys Thanks for Watching and Remember I'm Giving away Prizes now on every new Video all you have to do to qualify Is
Subscribe to my Channel ring the bell and
Selectively Notified When my next Videos get released the secret link to my giveaways will be Pinned in the Comments for The first 12 Hours
if you like what I'm doing Show your support right Now by giving this Video A big thumbs Up and Share with A friend I
Love You back I'll see you next Time